Summer is on it’s way and that means more
sun, more heat, and unfortunately, more ticks.
Hey everyone Julia here for DNews
Lyme disease is weird, mysterious, and can
be pretty stubborn.
Every tick season 300,000 Americans will become
infected according to The U.S. Centers for
Disease Control.
The symptoms are similar to a flu like fever
and aches, so a lot of cases go untreated.
Only 30,000 cases get reported each year.
But other symptoms can get worse.
much worse.
Like chronic debilitating joint pain.
You can get lyme disease from the bite of
a blacklegged (deer) tick.
But not all ticks carry the disease.
According to Paul Mead, chief of epidemiology
and surveillance activity at the CDC, one
out of every four or five ticks might be infected
in areas where the disease is very common.
There are a lot of misconceptions about lyme
disease.
Some people think that everyone who gets the
disease will get a telltale bulls eye redness
around the tick bite.
But that’s not always the case.
The CDC says around 70 percent of people get
the mark, but it can vary by region.
But lyme disease doesn’t vary too much,
it’s been reported in every state except
Hawaii.
The disease is caused by the bacteria Borrelia
burgdorferi.
This bacteria is old.
Like really old.
Researchers from Ohio State University found
ticks infected with it trapped in amber in
the Dominican Republic.
In a study published in the journal Historical
Biology, they found they could be around 15
to 20 MILLION YEARS OLD.
Basically as long as people have been getting
bit by ticks, there’s been lyme disease.
You know that famous Ice mummy otzi?
Yeah, he might’ve had Lyme disease.
In analyzing his genome, scientists found
fragments of the bacteria’s genetic material.
At 5,300 years old, that could be the oldest
case ever found of the disease.
Otzi, like others, would have suffered some
of the nasty symptoms like pain.
Most of the symptoms are caused by the way
the disease targets the immune system.
It triggers inflammation and can attack the
peripheral nervous system, causing pain spreading
from the back to the arms and legs, and hands
and feet.
One study published in the journal The American
Journal of Pathology found that this inflammation
can also affect the central nervous system,
causing headaches and fatigue and even scary
symptoms like memory loss, learning disability,
or depression.
Lyme disease can be cured if it’s caught
early, but it’s often misdiagnosed.
So sometimes these symptoms persist becoming
chronic and debilitating in about 10-20 percent
of patients.
It’s estimated that about a million Americans
live with what’s called post-treatment Lyme
disease (PTLD).
A recent study published in Antimicrobial
Agents and Chemotherapy found why it’s just
so hard to get rid of.
Even though lyme disease is caused by bacteria,
antibiotics often don’t work to treat the
pathogen.
So the bacteria forms what’s called dormant
persister cells which evade antibiotics.
And just like their name suggests these guys
aren’t killed by antibiotics.
They lie dormant.
Then might wake up after a round of treatment
and wreck havoc on the nervous system.
But the researchers also identified two potential
treatments for PTLD.
One is a treatment for cancer called Mitomycin
C, which wiped out all cultures of the bacteria.
But the treatment is pretty toxic, so probably
not the best way to go.
Another way involves multiple doses of antibiotics.
In what’s called “pulse dosing” the
researchers repeatedly dosed the bacteria.
In the first round, some cells died, but those
dormant persister cells didn’t.
They woke up and tried to establish a population.
But before they did, researchers hit them
with another round of antibiotics.
After four rounds of treatment, the bacteria
were all eradicated.
But this was only in a testtube, so more research
is needed.
IF you’re worried about lyme disease and
tick bites, the CDC recommends knowing where
deer ticks are commonly found, wearing protective
clothing and insect repellent if you go into
those areas and to do daily checks of your
body if you’ve been outside, even in your
own backyard.
If a tick is attached to your body for less
than 24 hours, your chances of getting the
disease is small.
Speaking of tiny things that could potentially
harm you, have you ever wondered what a virus
is?
I’ve got the short & sweet answer for you
in this episode of my new show, Test Tube
101.
Check it out and subscribe.